welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz
we're here for another episode of the 15
minutes with a mental series
today i'm joined by carl gallagher and
in this series we really simply ask the
mentors from inside the community
seven questions in 15 minutes so carl
for those that
may not know who you are if you
introduce yourself and then we'll get
into it
yeah thanks for thanks having me hisham
um so i'm kyle one of the
uh directors associate director at this
is prime and essentially what we do is
connect
the best mainly entry level talent with
the fastest growing
tech companies and sales teams across
the uk
and further further beyond love that so
first question for you is what was
your biggest challenge in 2020 how did
you overcome it
and what did you learn from it and the
biggest challenge and i'm sure you're
probably going to get this one a lot for
last year it had to be march
just before the pandemic hit um i'm sure
for most recruiters it was the same but
it was just
doomsday offers pulled um interviews
cancelled
um you know candidates unfortunately
being let go and
it was just a huge huge exodus and for
any recruiter when this stuff happens
it's difficult right
um so that was that was definitely the
the biggest challenge
um particularly for the junior members
of the team as well because a lot of
them hadn't experienced too many
knockbacks in recruitment and then for
it all to happen at once
you know it was a huge huge challenge
and how did we overcome it
we just stuck to what we've always tried
to do to be honest we didn't change too
much and we tried to have a really
rational and logical approach to the
situation and you have two choices
um you know you can carry on what you're
doing and still try to make a success
during difficult times
or you can really start to panic and get
concerned and lose focus so
and what we did was just continue with
our vision to try and change the
perception of sales
and still try and get the best talent
into the best sales jobs in the country
and that's what we did
and we had to pivot a little bit so we
now operate in the us
um for a couple of months afterwards we
launched a webinar series which
he obviously thankfully and uh very kind
of you joined us on uh which is a great
episode but the idea of
that was still to add value to sales
people and to business owners
in what was a difficult time and and the
learn
was just don't stand still stick to your
principles stick to whatever your vision
is
um you're just in a more difficult
situation to try and get through it
that's all you know it's all the same
i love that so the next question i have
for you and i'm sure this has sort of
been things that you've been learning
and
sort of sharing with your your team and
speak to people about but what
working from home tip could you share
with other recruiters that has had a
massive impact on your own
productivity that's a really good one
i i've probably got a few actually um so
one i've used recently
um i've been wearing jeans uh that
sounds so so
simple but i've been i've been put been
putting jeans off i've got jeans on
right now i've been trying to dress
only a little bit smarter you know still
very casual and
and it just really helps with your
mindset because you feel like you're
you're getting ready for something um
and although you're probably walking
from your bedroom to another bedroom or
to your dining room
it just helps that you're breaking that
up with actually i'm putting a pair of
jeans on i'm getting ready for the day
so that that has helped me recently
actually particularly with this
lockdowns i think this one has been
a bit more challenging for people you
know the weather's not as good we've got
the sunshine like we had last time
and this has been going on for over a
year so that that's helped me
in this lockdown particular um
and i think the other thing is just make
sure you organize um
and try and have as much separation as
possible you know i've heard and seen
many reports that
people are actually working longer now
they're being at home probably making
the most of the time they would
typically spend commuting
but it's still important that you have
that separation and so if that's you
work upstairs as soon as you come
downstairs
work is done for the day i think that's
really really important
because when your home becomes your work
it's very difficult to uh
to separate the two yeah nice great tips
there
so what has been the most effective way
for you to win business in the last 12
months
great question um being creative has
probably been the best one
um and in the last 12 months with it
being you know much more challenging
less businesses recruiting and still you
know the same
typical amount of recruiters going after
the same business it's
being hyper personalized making sure
you're targeting the right people
and for the right reasons um and you
know i've said it a couple of times
already but make sure you're actually
adding value to that person you're
trying to prospect
um so there that's probably been my main
tips really so the biggest success
i had was probably back in june july
time we're just sending a really
personalized video
um to a recruitment manager at a big
cyber security business
and at the time that was the only video
of its type they had received
they were looking to hire you know a big
team of sdrs in the uk and in the usa
um and i think what really worked well
there was just the personalization
it stood out and it was different um so
that's been the most effective for me
really just doing whatever you can do
to stand out from the crowd i think is
more important now than it than it's
probably ever been before
yeah i love that just being open minded
isn't it to try different things and
yeah i love that
so what habit or hobby did you start in
2020 that you're gonna continue in 2021
wow um probably doing videos
was definitely one that was a work habit
and i think the key with that is
consistency you know you can do one
video it doesn't work it's easy to give
it up
um but just set yourself a target of
however many you want to do on a weekly
basis i think he's key
and doing it over a long period of time
the hobby um
has probably been running so we we
actually set up a work
uh running club um in the first lockdown
um
and money to get my 5k time from
probably 29 minutes to just under 23.
i've heard i've heard like that's just
made you all hate neil moore this
running club because he's just
constantly pounding the pavement mate oh
you know he is massively but he was it
was really funny though we had them
we're trying to get as many people
involved in the group as possible and
and one of the guys in london his uh his
girlfriend
uh was added to the group and and the
first run she posted i think it was was
a half marathon in
in just under two hours or two hours wow
and that beat neil's time
so the next day the next
but it was it was good to have that
camaraderie so that that for me is
you know going to be one uh my aim is to
do a marathon this year um
off the back of that um yeah so yeah
we'll see
so i so i wanna know carl like what
which do you think is better the first
coffee in the morning or the first
post work on a friday uh definitely
definitely the first time definitely the
first pine i've actually
tried to cut down on coffee a bit i'm
not sure about you but
um i think if you have too much during
the day um then i think you can end up
crashing and burning a little bit
earlier um
whereas after that first pint you're
done for the day then so you can
probably enjoy it
nice right so this one's slightly
different i just want to give you a
scenario and i'm just interested to
hear hear how you would approach it so
the scenario is
a particular business you've had on your
target client list for over a year long
period of time
during that time you've had a number of
touch points with different people in
that business they might have engaged
some of your content
you might send them a video over email
you've had different touch points
but through your candidate network you
managed to get one of the hiring
manager's contact details so you call
that person
they pick up they say hello who is this
and interested to hear how you'd
approach that
yeah um relevant question actually so um
one of the businesses we bought on i
actually did linkedin post about it
yesterday so the business that we
um recently been working where we were
with them a couple of years ago we
placed an sdr there 18 months ago
and they've now progressed into a
management role and are now
recruiting for their team and working
with us to do so and that client
was brought on in exactly the scenario
that you just mentioned
exactly the same way um so the way i
would approach it
um i would just go in look i've been
past your details by this person
now the key here is um and i've
mentioned this in my previous video
is this only works if the person that
you've been recommended into by you've
delivered an amazing experience for
previously so this only is effective
when you do that but the way i would
approach it is just go
look you know person x is recommended we
get in touch and i would talk about
their journey and their experience
the reason i believe they wanted to put
me in touch with you was based on the
experience that they had
we were able to do this for them and
look how well they're doing now in your
business
why don't we have a chat about how we
can support your sales team how's that
going for you right now
so that's probably how i would approach
that call but it only works
if you know you deliver great
experiences for people all the time if
not then obviously it could backfire a
little bit
yeah no i like that brilliant so final
question
is i want you to imagine that i'm a
recruiter or recruiters listening to
this and
they've set their goals for 2021 they're
feeling motivated they
are completely convinced they're gonna
have a better year this year than they
are
2020. and i just want to sort of hear
what your advice would be to me and the
recruiters listening
that you think would give us the best
possible chance of achieving the goals
that we've set this year
yeah um i think the first bit of advice
i would give probably taking it right
back to the beginning is make sure you
probably revisit and just check your
goals one that they're realistic but i
think the key thing is make sure
make sure you really want them you know
a goal is only as powerful as how much
you really want to achieve it
if you set a goal that you're not that
bothered to achieve the how you're going
to do it doesn't really matter
um doesn't really help but once you have
you know done that make sure your goals
are realistic
you can measure them you really want to
achieve them and then you need to start
working on
how you're going to make that a reality
and the key thing is just breaking it
down like it's really really simple
a 12 month goal you can lose focus you
can get a bit disillusioned but if you
break that 12-month goal down into well
actually every single month i just need
to do this or
even better every single week i need to
do this you know it's much more
manageable and i think you're much more
likely to achieve it but
yeah i think the key part of that
question is is the first bit i think the
goals
have to be strong enough you have to
really want them and then i think the
how
you know you need to think about that
but i think if the goals are good enough
you'll you'll do whatever it takes and
you will make them happen
so i would spend more time making sure
the goals are you know
really really strong yeah love that car
that's 15 minutes with the mentor that
was it
thank you so much no thank you
appreciate it